Харківщина, 47 кілометрів до лінії фронту.
У цій зарослій бур'яном місцевості непросто впізнати село Довгеньке.
Унаслідок російських обстрілів тут не залишилося жодної вцілілої хати.
Та серед руїн з одного подвір'їв доноситься рев єдиного робочого трактора.
Працює!
Ну хоч щось, я вам скажу!
Ігор Князєв - один з дев'яти постійних жителів села Довгеньке.
Дві школи було, дитсадок, клуб великий.
Та ну все було! У нас було все абсолютно!
Але тепер не буде нічого…
Перед тим, як показати, що сталося з його рідним селом,
Ігор з радістю демонструє DW те єдине, що його тут втішає -
перший врожай воєнного часу на своєму городі.
Ось огірки уже є! Бачите, які!
Проблеми виростити немає, проблема - розмінувати.
Якби хтось поміг розмінувати - було би простіше.
Міни були тут на всіх городах. Це був передок, звідти йшов наступ.
Стягував, а потім виносив, її не можна ні крутити, ні вертіти, тому що хто її знає!
Я шість городів, оце один у мене, я ще 5 розмінував, сам ходив.
Село Довгеньке у березні торік опинилося на лінії оборони шляху до Слов'янська.
Щоденно тут велися запеклі танкові бої просто посеред вулиць.
А з квітня у хатах місцевих оселилися російські окупанти,
які тримали село під контролем аж до вересня.
Такого сценарію, каже Ігор, ніхто не очікував.
Ми просто не розуміли, що робити. Поки взяли Ізюм, поки взяли Кам’янку,
а потім вже сюди почало прилітати. Просто люди не розуміли, люди мали надію,
що все буде нормально, що все відіб'ють. 12 людей загинуло.
Чекали, висиджували. У мене батя 3 людини знайшов...
Зайшов, а вони всі троє там лежали. Приліт був, і жахнуло…
З перших днів повномасштабного нападу РФ на Україну староста села втік.
Минулої весни евакуювалася і більшість місцевих.
Наприкінці березня торік виїхали і Князєви. Але за півроку після звільнення Довгенького
родина повернулася. І застала на своєму подвір'ї лише згарище.
Ось, воно видно, що це зерно.
Пшениці було 50 тонн, а насіння 30. На мільйончик лежало зерна.
Вже звідси повитягували частину тракторів.
Комбайн згорів повністю.
Оце тут вівці жили, вони тут їли, ось одні кісточки залишилися з овець,
вони зараз по кущах валяються, ось шерсть, видно, що були баранці.
Та попри це все Ігор та його родина вірять,
що зможуть самотужки відновити господарство.
Щоб ось це хоч щось зберегти, навіть металобрухт, треба було тут бути.
Ухвалив рішення, що треба лишатися і все.
Лишилися, жили у підвалі всі.
Оскільки хата повністю зруйнована, цієї весни волонтери надали Ігорю,
його матері та батькові тимчасовий дах над головою -
ось цей модульний будинок. Щоправда, тут відсутні газ, вода та електрика.
Синок сьогодні привіз помідорчики і молоко.
А як він працює без електрики?
Та ніяк не працює, це просто…
Ну, вода технічна. З водою тут проблеми.
Ось тут криниця. Насос вставлений, оце по трубі ми її качаємо.
Питну воду і продукти родина купує у місті Ізюм, за 23 кілометри звідси.
Електричну плитку та інші прилади підключають до дизельного генератора.
Діду, на твою чашку.
68-річний батько Ігоря - Анатолій Князєв - кається, що колись вважав росіян братами,
до яких пів села роками їздило на заробітки.
Ну, та яке ж тепер ставлення до братів! Раніше думали, нормально…
І я в молодості в Москві робив.
Тепер їх тільки треба перебити всіх, щоб до нас не лізли!
З руїн, що по собі лишили російські окупанти, родина знайшла дещо,
що згодилося у побуті. Цю кухню, де усі п'ють чай, Ігор з батьком самі
побудували з ящиків з-під російських "Градів". До зими Князєви планують
добудувати з них і нове житло - кілька кімнат над відновленою котельнею.
Ось це все будувалося з нуля.
Ось це сходи на другий поверх. Їх ще треба робити, але ніколи поки робити.
Це спальня, я іноді тут сплю. Ну, поки з вікнами проблема.
У перерві між хатніми справами батько Ігоря - Анатолій Князєв -
прогулюється із собакою та вівцями рідною вулицею і дивиться,
чи не повернувся хтось до сусідських хат.
До повномасштабної війни тут жило 760 людей,
серед яких і багато етнічних росіян, каже чоловік.
Отут Володя Бобрусь. Росіяни - одна родина була раніше.
40 років, як вже тут живуть. А тепер вони під Дніпро утекли.
А рідня в нього в Росії. І як оце бути йому з ними,
якщо вони розбили йому хату?
На дорозі досі лежать танкові снаряди.
Віталька! Ти вдома?
Лише в одній хаті застаємо господаря. Віталій теж виїжджав із Довгенького
і повернувся минулої осені. У нього немає половини будинка,
попри це він продовжує розводити у дворі кролів і бджіл.
Вони вас чіпати не будуть! Вони спокійні в мене!
Он війною побило там два вулики.
Побило, порозліталися… А оце знайшов коробки. Ось один, он ще один.
Повітря свіже! Ну от у мене зараз родина в місті.
Мама з донькою. Приїжджаю до них іноді, ну, не те!
Не те повітря! Тут все одно легше дихати!
Як обгороджуся, сарайчик зроблю! Баранів ще заведу.
Пасіку далі зроблю.
Зараз у селі постійно мешкають 9 людей. Могло би бути більше,
однак кілька місцевих, які повернулися додому, загинули на власних подвір'ях
- підірвалися на розтяжках або мінах.
Був у нас тут знайомий, загинув. Підірвалися хлопці.
Вони приїхали теж отак, як Ігор, намагалися відбудовуватися, мали землю.
Пішли, хотіли, мабуть, худобу знайти якусь, пішли, і на розтяжці підірвалися.
Юлія з чоловіком приїхали до свого дому, аби вивезти звідси
нову партію металобрухту. Кажуть, цим займається більшість тих,
хто не може тут лишитися жити. Це залізяччя - останнє, що можна продати.
Усе інше цінне серцю майно перетворилося на попіл.
Що у нас тут було? Літня кухня, гараж, два сараї.
У нас коли перший приліт був, у нас якраз в той день свиня опоросилася.
У нас було 18 свиней. Випустили. Два дорослих бика, дві корови.
Курочки, нутрії, кролики, собаки, коти. Все було, ну так…
Звільнили вже так звільнили! Що можна сказати…
Те, яким село було колись, розповідатимуть онукам, каже Ігор Князєв.
Вже ніхто сюди не вернеться. Тому що ті поїхали за кордон,
ті купили вже дім, того взагалі нема, убило…
Я думаю, лишаться лише господарства. Хто витримає! Бо ж усе заміновано…
У села Довгеньке є потенціал - сільськогосподарський, кажуть Князєви.
Нині найголовніше для родини - продати цьогорічний урожай
з розмінованого городу і полагодити ще придатні трактори.
Це шанс відродити улюблену справу на рідній землі.